is the pride of Tenafly New Jersey
everybody right here on the Rich Eisen
show loved them for so many years in TV
shows like The OC damages just fantastic
and then films Argo Manchester by the
sea and now in theaters near you Rocket
Man good to see you take Donovan it's
awesome to be here thrilled to have you
here you know uh ed Harris is from
Tenafly manager is that right they
played football with my brother no
kidding yes you've known that you know
Ned for a while well you know I was 10
when he was playing football okay
we didn't get into great conversation is
that the list of of Tenafly New Jersey
host Davis
you know she's a great actress I do know
that and Mia Sorvino oh no yeah we all
went to high school did you really yeah
so when you were just hanging out in
high school did you go to the Sorvino
house hold the job no no I didn't know
yeah she was a little bit younger
younger than you but hope Davis I went
to the hook Davis household many times
many times my best friend dated her and
you've lived to tell about it
yeah yeah live to tell about it now last
time I saw you sir was in Atlanta
Georgia where you were at the NFL honors
broadcast that was awesome night you're
right there yeah so now I was right
behind you no effect
yeah I think you turned around and said
keep it down and you said down in front
what brought you to the NFL honors well
I did some voiceovers for the NFL and
the Super Bowl but what really brought
me yes was I'm married to a woman who's
from Wisconsin yes and there are three
people in the world that she wants to
meet okay Brett Favre yes Aaron Rodgers
yes and you that's not true that is so
true she is obsessed with your show she
watches it all I mean you know it's it
I'm cool with it
I'm cool okay she watches your show
every day she loves your show thank you
and every day I'm like you know I know
that dude I'm yeah many times
how about me many times yeah he's
awesome she and she always she's always
like well then if he's such a good
friend why how come you not on his show
and here you're saving on
uniter tape you are you do realize
though that when this sentence begins
with Brett Favre Aaron Rodgers the third
is usually like Bart Starr right yeah
yeah it's like that's I know that
exactly that's usually the way I know
that sentence end exactly so I am very
you're in a salad company because I met
your wife that night I know she's
satisfied she can live a happy life that
was a fun night by the way it was
awesome that was a great night so much
Harvey was hilarious right and then just
I love what they have done with the the
awards used to be tape they used to be
just announced on a Wednesday night one
by Wednesday night hey guess who the
coach the year is and it just would be
released by The Associated Press either
caught wind of it or not now it's just a
whole big to do well or a myth you know
her of course she's fantastic and she's
she's Miss ESPY Awards and now she's
doing this as well that's where my wife
first met Aaron Rodgers oh she's like
can we get to the ESPYs I want to meet
Aaron Rodgers and Aaron was so sweet to
us and we he took a picture with us and
my wife yes put it it's on it's our
Christmas card right is a picture with
Aaron Rodgers it's like merry Christmas
from merry Christmas from us yes and and
it's a picture of me us and Aaron
Rodgers so we tell him this at the NFL
this is the level of fandom that I live
with every day I don't even care about
football hmm I mean I'm not a huge
football fan right yeah but now I am you
know now on the talk are you interested
in the Packers based on okay has your
wife met far as she completed though she
yes she met far of that night that night
yeah and and the the funny thing is is
that so we saw Aaron Rodgers again yes
and we said hey you know you're on our
Christmas card he's like no way and I'm
like we are and so we showed him the
picture and he was I think he might have
been a little weird
you know athletes of that stature or
have to be used to hearing things you
know I named my kid everybody yes or
that or my dog's name at a Christmas
card
that's a little weird person very very
personal when you say hey yeah this is
what we've done that's the most
important thing they've done all year
what we've done is a family and it's
aaron rodgers it's like you know kids
doing well in school
amazing movies aaron rodgers well that's
a Packer fan for you right it is that is
it's a Wisconsin Packer fan so Tate
Donovan here on the Rich Eisen show so
growing up in New Jersey there wasn't a
giant or a jet or anybody or a nick or
somebody that is in New York that might
that left out at you is well yeah I mean
I like the Knicks and I like you know
the the Jets a little bit more because
I'm from New Jersey sure the Giants are
sort of Long Island or you know
Manhattan kind of right but the I was
always in love with the Lakers for some
unknown reason I well will Chamberlain
was just playing then and he was seven
feet and I was like a kid and you know
how like kids love the tallest biggest
so I got into Lakers and then I went to
USC where I met grant Heslov and magic
was playing for the Lakers then and then
you know I read about Kobe Bryant you
know 17 year old kid and he spoke fluent
Italian and I was like I love this kid
you love it you were locked in right so
I've been locked in for since I was 10
well I mean no just I guess circle back
to that and if L honours Knight Namath
was there I know that and that for me
yeah did you have you ever shook his
hand I have it she's huge it's like a
baseball hi oh and you but you could see
why he's got a great spiral that that
like is I don't know this is gonna sound
weird I know the contours of the man's
hand but I'm a fan but it's like his his
index finger is the longest finger on
his hand and so that's how he can I know
you're looking at me weird right no I
just told you that
Rogers is on our Christmas card I mean I
understand the weirdness but here's the
weirdness on my wife and ours a Hanukkah
card it's me and Namath okay yes no I'm
just kidding
[Laughter]
but no I do know that it's just when I
shake his hand I'm like wow that's a
very large yeah hand
I know must be the MVP of Super Bowl
three you know we can make it that we
can make it that there is right there
there's my that he is my childhood idol
yeah he was awesome Joe Namath yeah for
sure
take Donovan here on the riches Joe
let's talk about your movie Rocket Man I
am a die-hard Elton John fan you play
the owner of the Troubadour here in Los
Angeles California where Elton made his
debut what was it like going back in
time and and and recreating the birth of
Elton if it was a blast it was a total
blast first of all I got to wear a wig
which I I've never acted with a wig
before come on
and I sort of didn't want to act with
the wig I was like talking to the
director I was like really man yeah you
know and I put that wig on and it was
like oh I know what I'm doing mm-hmm it
was so much fun we had we had a blast
and Taron Egerton
is DBC his performance right it is he is
at once what's one of the fiercest
performances I've ever seen and also
incredibly vulnerable I think that's a
surprising thing about this movie like
oh I love Elton and his music lalala and
you know he had a troubled troubles with
drugs and stuff like that but this movie
is so surprising because you really it's
very emotional film it's really it's
great
it turned did all the singing in it did
all the singing and piano playing get
out this is sanely talented Wow
insanely if I could only imagine you
know the pressure of acting and
portraying somebody right okay
acting and portraying Elton John and
then singing and playing the piano I
know I I don't know how you could pull
something I know
me doing all their songs all of his
songs I mean you know they they switch
the songs around and and and orchestrate
it into the movie right unbelievably
beautifully and Elton has been a
champion of this film I mean he he
worked on the script and he just turned
to Dexter Fletcher who directed it and
just said it's a masterpiece I mean it's
yeah actually I'm such a fan of Elton
John's and I was hoping somehow someway
cuz he does live part of the year in
Atlanta yeah and he is an NFL fan I met
him once cuz he was at the opening of a
season in New England Robert Kraft the
owner of the Patriots has invited Elton
John to performed know that one at one
of the I don't know which of the many
Super Bowl championship postgame
celebrations and I met him there I was
kind of like hoping somehow someway that
I would see him at the Super Bowl but
alas that was not to be you did all your
own talking in the movie right yeah I
can't be bothered to talk during a movie
you were the voice of Hercules I was oh
I you know so I done some of your own
voice I can speak exactly your own
speaking words just pointing that on
freedom celebrity true or false with
with take Donovan here where we we've
called some some aspects from certain
articles in your IMDB page to see what's
true and what's false okay here we go
with take Donovan on the Rich Eisen show
new celebrity true or false
[Music]
okay that's the next new there you go
okay so first up give me get a little
bit of a little bit of music here Mike
tell - faux fur take Donovan in and
Rocket Man right near in a theater near
you
first up you kept one of the wigs from
Rocket Man you kept it is a true story
fortunately false you did not I did not
I wish I did though it freaked my son
out totally he saw he we came to set and
so you've never once in anything you've
ever done over acted with a wig yeah
single show open that I've done for the
Superbowl on this show I've worn away we
did Smokey and the Bandit open for
Georgia I wore wig
we did a Friday Night Lights open for
our Super Bowl in Houston I wore a wig
some up I mean I mix but only in the
privacy of my own home watching Johnson
show how if your work I'm wearing a wig
right now yeah can you tell it's
beautiful
up for bids right here in celebrity true
or false would take Donovan you know how
to play a number of instrument including
the fiddle and a bod Rana a hammer on
brawn pardon pardon me that's okay is
this a true story that's totally true
yeah I played in a Irish pub for four
years every Tuesday night surprised you
didn't come and see my mom alone the the
Irish band the MacGuffins that's there
you go now is that a reference to Alfred
Hitchcock it is look at me look at me
right now yeah no you're a film buff
well I'm a film buff I know what a
MacGuffin is I do it's okay something
that you think should be paid attention
to but it's something that is completely
that's a false herring that's a red
herring I thought that's what I
MacGuffin is a MacGuffin is something
that only lives in the world of the
movie and it doesn't exist like in
Casablanca yes the letters of transport
that they were all saying there's no
such thing as let it like there'd be
letters that knots you'd be like oh
you've got the letters of transport you
write this way you know like so it was
the MacGuffin in North by Northwest if I
just throw it out here too
Christ unfortunately your graded true or
false you participated in the New York
Marathon in 2005 and finished sub three
and a half hours yes totally true yo
that is highly impressive not really
what are you talking about I two
brothers who ran the marathon their
first time and my one of my brothers ran
a 2:47 his first time mm-hmm
and I also had another brother who after
a couple of marathons ran 228 okay so by
the time I came around up I'll be it
they were in their 30s and I ran it when
I was 44 or something like that
dude you ran a 40-foot you ran a
marathon at age 44 and three and a half
hours or less and you're like that's not
that big of a deal and my family it's no
big deal
[Laughter]
my parents are watching said they know
we would never do something like that
okay and last one one of your first
feature films was with a very young
Joaquin Phoenix Kelly Preston and Lea
Thompson in the 1986 Jem Space Camp true
or false it was a gem great movie you
loved it right loved that movie as a kid
want maybe want to go to Space Camp Kate
Capshaw right Kate Capshaw yeah yeah
yeah that that you know that movie was a
giant bomb I mean it like tanked because
it came out like three months after the
Space Shuttle exploded only only
children right you're like the perfect
age to like Space Camp right because
anybody older than that was like oh my
gosh that's you know and you're in your
first on screen credit 1984 as Clancy
and family ties is that you were falling
oh that's very true you really do your
research well you know we're buttoned up
here you know your wife wouldn't want
you on any just overnight fly by night
so true and she really cares for me so
was there any tension on the set of
family ties based on your recollection
at all
know why actually I had never seen
family ties when I got the job and so I
hadn't like one line in it yes and so we
did this reading before before we did
the reading the script yes Michael J Fox
who's a huge star it was like the first
year but still I should have seen the
show and known who the stars were and I
was like and he's I came in I didn't
look in the show Mike and and I was like
oh yeah who do you play he just looked
at me like is that why you didn't get a
gig and back future Rocket Man is doing
great in theaters near you it was
released just a last week and it is
great to have you here come back anytime
seriously thanks for saving my marriage
I was about to say but I mean you know
no but it's legitimate say hi Cory okay
hi Cory
thanks for sending your husband my wife
sound good
thanks for coming on Thanks hey Donovan
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app